>> Jeanine: THE RED WAVE WARNING
GROWING MORE INTENSE FOR
DEMOCRATS AS PRESIDENT BIDEN
CONTINUES HIS FREE FALL IN THE
POLLS.
SWING STATE VOTERS ARE
REPORTEDLY GETTING BUYER'S
REMORSE.
WITH THE PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL
SINKING FAST IN SEVERAL
BATTLEGROUND STATES LIKE
MICHIGAN, VIRGINIA AND IOWA.
MAKING MATTERS WORSE FOR BIDEN,
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS FEUDING
OVER ASPECTS OF HIS TRILLION
DOLLAR SPENDING AGENDA.
OKAY.
ON THE ONE HAND, YOU KNOW, JOE
BIDEN, I'LL START WITH YOU,
DANA, JOE BIDEN SAID HE WAS
GOING TO UNIFY I'VE.
IT APPEARS HE CAN'T UNIFY HIS
OWN PARTY.
HE HAS THE PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATS
AND THE MORE MODERATE DEMOCRATS
AND THE 3.5 TRILLION SPENDING
BILL THAT IS, YOU KNOW,
APPARENTLY CAUSING A LOT OF
PEOPLE TO SAY WE DIDN'T VOTE FOR
HIM TO DO THIS.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
BIDEN SAID HE WON THE PRIMARY HE
WAS MORE MODERATE AND
PROGRESSIVE LIKE BERNIE SANDERS.
THEN HE BECAME PRESIDENT AND NOW
HE'S BEING LED AROUND BY THE
NOSE BY THE PROGRESSIVES, THE
BERNIE SANDERS CROWD.
THE MODERATES THAT HAVE VERY
TOUGH RACES THAT NEED SOMETHING
TO BRING HOME, THEY WANT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL AND THEN
TALK ABOUT THE $3.5 TRILLION.
THE 3.5 TRILLION HAS THE
PROGRESSIVES WORRIED.
THEY'RE IN A STALEMATE.
INSTEAD OF MEETING WITH
REPUBLICANS TO GET THEM TO
SUPPORT THE BILLS, HE'S MEETING
WITH HIS OWN PEOPLE.
HE MIGHT HAVE SOME SUCCESS
THERE.
MIGHT FIGURE OUT A WAY TO SAVE
FACE AND BRINGS THINGS TOGETHER.
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS IS, HE'S
MISHANDLING THESE OTHER ISSUES,
THE BORDER, AFGHANISTAN,
INFLATION BEING ANOTHER ISSUE
THAT -- AND CRIME.
LET ME ADD THAT ONE.
THAT IT'S MAKING HIS POLITICAL
CAPITAL ACCOUNT DECREASE.
>> Jeanine: LOOK AT IOWA.
HIS APPROVAL RATING IS 31% IN
IOWA.
I MEAN, THAT IS PRETTY --
>> Greg: NO HIGHER THAN
GERALDO'S THOUGH.
>> Geraldo: NOT IN CLEVELAND.
>> Jeanine: HIS JOB APPROVAL IS
43% OVERALL.
IOWA, AN IMPORTANT STATE.
31%.
IT'S LIKE DON'T SHOW UP THERE.
>> Greg: JOE'S APPROVAL WAS AT
HIS HIGHEST WHEN HE WASN'T
WORKING.
WHEN HE WAS IN HIDING.
HE WAS THE PLAYER TO BE NAMED
LATER OR OTHER.
THE MORE HE DOES HIS JOB, THE
FASTER HIS APPROVAL EVAPORATES.
SO MY SOLUTION FOR HIM IF I WAS
RUNNING, IF I WAS HIS CHIEF OF
STAFF, CRYOGENICS.
FREED HIM UNTIL 2022.
DEFROST HIM LIKE A SWANSON'S
DINNER, BAKE, BACK BETTER.
THAT WOULD BE HIS NEW THING.
EVERYTHING YOU'RE SAYING IS
CORRECT.
NOBODY IS BUYING MODERATE JOE
ANYMORE.
HE'S LIKE -- GERALDO WILL
REMEMBER THIS.
LIKE ONE OF THE TOWNS THAT THEY
USED IN WESTERN TV SHOWS.
THEY CAN FALL YOU UNTIL IT FALLS
OVER.
>> Geraldo: YOU'RE
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST OLDER
PEOPLE.
>> Jeanine: WHAT DO YOU SAY,
GERALDO?
>> Geraldo: I THINK THAT JOE
BIDEN'S COAT TAILS ARE
SHRINKING.
I THINK THE BIGGEST IMPACT IS
NOT THE MID-TERM ELECTION.
I THINK YOU HAVE THE 3.5
TRILLION OMNIBUS SPENDING BILL
THAT REQUIRES ALL 50 SENATORS.
CINEMA AND MANCHIN WILL BE
EMPOWERED BY HIS DIMINISHING
POPULARITY.
IF YOU CAN'T GET 50 SENATORS ON
THE FLOOR, WILL THIS COLLAPSE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, THE 1.9
TRILLION INFRASTRUCTURE BILL?
WILL THIS HAMPER HIS ABILITY TO
LIFT THE DEBT CEILING AND THE
REST OF IT?
I THINK THAT IF HE IS WOUNDED AS
THIS BEFORE THE FIRST YEAR IS
EVEN OUT, IT DOES SPELL
PROBLEMS.
I'M NO BIG POLITICAL EXPERT BUT
IT SPELLS PROBLEMS.
>> Jeanine: WITH MANCHIN AND
SINEMA, THEY CAN'T CONVINCE THEM
TO TURN AROUND, JOE BIDEN.
>> Jesse: I'LL BE BRIEF.
I WANT TO SAVE TIME FOR
GERALDO'S APOLOGY TO GUTFELD.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU NOTICED
THIS, BY MY FRIENDS AND FAMILY
THAT ARE DEMOCRAT, THEY DON'T
DEFEND BIDEN.
I ASK THEM HOW IS IT GOING,
GUYS?
OH, DON'T LOOK AT ME.
IT'S TRUE.
NOBODY IS A BIDEN VOTER.
IT'S LIKE BEING A CARTER VOTER.
IT HAS A STENCH LOFTING AROUND
FROM IT.
>> Geraldo: I LIKED JIMMY
CARTER.
>> Jesse: HE LIES AND HIDES.
WE KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
JOE.
IT'S A MATTER OF NEXT YEAR, IS
HE SO TOXIC IN THESE SWING
STATES IN THE 30s STILL, ARE
THEY GOING TO DISTANCE
THEMSELVES FROM JOE BIDE